Disney
just dropped a trailer for a new film
and
this is funny to me because they they
hope that it'll be their next big hit
which would be their first big hit in a
while
Disney's trying to get back on track
like Disney is is way off track right
now they've had a lot of flops
and uh obviously this is a legendary
movie studios put out some of the
classic films of all time and uh but
recently it's been nothing but terrible
movies and big flops and everything so I
got this big one he's got a lot of hype
already
because it's supposed like tailor-made
to be
this is it's like everything all the
algorithms it's it's all engineered for
that to be a big Blockbuster hit and the
movie is called
wish and one of the things that the
studio is excited about and the people
behind the film you know they've talked
about in interviews is that this movie
will see The Return of the classic
Disney villain so this is not what we
see recently in Disney movies this is
not a tragic villain or an unintentional
villain like in whatever Frozen or
something this is like a classic Disney
villain just an evil person who's evil
for the sake of it like in the old days
um straightforward bad guy who is voiced
by Chris Pine because of course you
already know that if Disney's putting an
actual villain in a movie it has to be a
white guy it's the most predictable
the result ever is when you hear that uh
Disney's got a real classic villain in
there oh it's a white guy of course it
is and you already know also that the
hero of course is a non-white girl all
that you already know but what's great
about this trailer is that you can you
can tell immediately this movie is going
to be garbage that's Disney desperately
trying to get back on track
you could tell just from the trailer
that this is a miss
and and you could say that I'm not the
target demo for this trailer so
obviously I think that but actually I am
you know I have six kids I have two
daughters I'm the one who has to pay for
the movie ticket I'm the target demo
and uh I won't be paying for tickets for
this but let's watch a little bit of
this trailer here it is
[Music]
become what if I told you that place is
within reach
[Music]
all you have to do
is give your
[Music]
s
so the the plot of the film is that we
didn't even see it in that clip but the
the prince is uh or the the evil bad
guys this white guy and he's a king and
he has uh he has the ability to grant
wishes and all the wishes in the kingdom
are sent to him and then he decides who
gets to who gets to uh Grant the wishes
and uh but but he's not going to Grant
everyone's wish
and then the uh the heroic brown girl
finds out that he is able to Grant all
these wishes but he chooses not to he
only wants to Grant the wishes that are
uh that he thinks are gonna be best for
the kingdom and the common good and
she's very upset about that and so then
she goes out to make sure that she can
grant all the wishes so this is uh this
is what it's great
um Disney doing everything they can't
get back on track to really have a major
hit
and and uh and all they have to do is
just make a classic and like an actual
classic Disney film they already have
you already have
the the road map right in front of you
it's it's there just go back and look at
what you did 30 years ago and do that
but they can't do it they just can't do
it they're incapable Grand Canyon
University is an affordable private
Christian University that's located in
beautiful Phoenix Arizona has a vibrant
and expansive campus ranked top 20 in
the country according to niche.com uh
praise for its culture of community
giving and impact GCU integrates the
free market system and a welcoming
Christian worldview Perspective into
over 320 academic programs with more
than 260 programs online as of March of
2023 earn your bachelor's Masters or
doctoral degree where you engage with
faculty and connect with your own
University counselor who takes a
personalized approach for your success
find your purpose at Grand Canyon
University private Christian affordable
visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
so the issue here and we'll leave aside
the underwhelming animation style I mean
the animation
in all these moves not just Disney but
in all these kids movies now it it it
like it just looks cheap doesn't look
artistic it's not interesting it's kind
of lifeless and Bland and all the rest
of it but leaving that aside in an
effort to put out a blockbuster crowd
pleaser they've made a film where the
villain is an evil white man who refuses
to Grant everyone's wishes and needs to
be vanquished by the heroic brown girl
who will create a Utopia by letting
everyone get exactly what they want
which is really a it's like a it's like
a parody of a modern Disney film
and the funny thing is that the movies
are getting so woke that they now
undercut their own messaging because in
this case the guy who's supposed to be
the villain
is like clearly the good guy and yes
Disney has always had a problem where
their villains are actually kind of
right
we've talked before about Gaston in uh
in the Beauty and the Beast he was
basically right I mean he at the very
least he had a point
but here it's kicked into overdrive the
evil King is absolutely correct that you
can't Grant everybody's wishes
in fact in fact if you had the power
to grant wishes
the the morally correct thing would be
to either Grant nobody's wishes probably
the would be best
or only a few
and the ones that you would Grant are
the ones that Advance the common good
and the good of the kingdom and that
that's the only way to do it that's the
actual correct wise approach very
clearly I think to almost everyone
which is why the comments on this video
is like everyone this trailer everyone
watches the trailer and says what do you
mean that guy's right
what's what's the point here
so that's dizzy they just can't they at
this point they are incapable of
creating anything that comes close to
their classic films if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt Walsh Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed